when the pandemic hit and of course in
different parts of the country you have
more
opening than than other parts of the
country so you know it really is still
uh a circumstance that has been hanging
over
large parts of our nation and certainly
the world for
a year yeah still hanging and here's
what happens
when uncertainty takes hold of us
and i think that's john that's what i
just sensed is
since covet came in i just there's
financial uncertainty
professional uncertainty it has
exacerbated and made worse
relationship uncertainty and boy boy we
humans just don't do very well
with uncertainty do we no and i think
most of us do one of two things right we
clamp down yeah and try to grab
everything we can and
and fake certainty or you just
take off running right you you cover up
in the corner and just let the world
spin at you
right and it's finding the strength and
the community and the relationships
and the the purpose to get in the middle
of that right
control those small things and then let
go of the other things right well we
talked about i believe it was
oh i'm going to say two or three i think
it may have been early april dave ramsey
rachel cruz and myself we did a live
event here from our headquarters
uh and we talked about was it called a
night of hope and the message that we
drove home that night was that
you control the controllables focus on
what you can control there's so much in
this world that we cannot control
yeah one of the things i talk a lot
about on the ken coleman show and
helping people
live and work on purpose is what happens
when you're in a place of uncertainty or
in a place of confusion what do you do
because that's that's an overwhelming
feeling the advice that i give is
something that i do in my own life is
that i retreat
to clarity so if i'm in a place where
i'm in financial uncertainty or
professional uncertainty relationship
uncertainty and i'm realizing right now
there's a lot of things spinning around
i mean i can't control it john i start
to go okay
i'm gonna retreat for a second not from
the world i'm not gonna go to a cave and
disappear
but what i am gonna do is i'm gonna just
step back for a moment whatever that
looks like get some perspective
that's it i call it getting clear just
get clear what well now what can i be
clear on
i'm clear that my wife stacy's counting
on me
my three kids are counting on me yeah
i you know whatever if that's if that's
clear
get there and when i get there i go okay
that means i can't quit
no matter how bad i'm hurting no matter
what's going on in my world
there are other people counting on me my
team's counting on me
right the ken coleman show has a team
there are people that are listening
every day they're counting on me to show
up so for you in those moments i'm just
going to tell you
step back and get clear get clear
financially wait a second what do i have
to do
to just pay the bills the four walls
that's what we teach whatever your
situation relationally how do people get
clear when it feels like their whole
world's spinning on them
yeah i think what i love when you say
that just you got to back up for a
second slow down stop
right get some perspective yeah um
and then sometimes ken like and this
weekend's a great example
um you step back and you just got to sit
down for a second right so i was telling
you off air
um i hope i can get through this we um
hey man the world lost a really
remarkable guy
yeah um from a community that i spent
many years in
a guy i've known for a long long time
named mark rogers in abilene texas
um in a senseless unfathomable
car accident with his three lovely
little kids and his extraordinary wife
who's a long time friend
um president of big brothers big sisters
a community leader and get this this is
a story i don't ever tell
it was a dinner we had together years
ago when he started his little podcast
it was the first podcast i ever did
about being well outside inside
relationships what does
wellness look like outside of what we've
been told and
so ken my instinct is just like yours to
pull back and say okay they're counting
on me i got to go back
in sometimes you lose a body when you
lose a light
you got to sit down and just grieve it
man that's right and so it's been a
quiet weekend at the deloney house
sitting there reflecting on um
sometimes life happens at you right and
we're on the show talking a lot about
how much advice we give and you got to
do this
and i think it's it's a um
it's dishonest and and um not truthful
those are two separate things right it's
just dishonest not to say hey
life comes at us too yeah right well and
so yeah we had a crazy thing it's not a
death
with a friend but we lost our beloved
riggins this morning
yeah yeah long time f and here's the
thing here's what we do
unexpected and i'm dying right now of
course because my wife's at home she's
about right tell the kids
it's like what is going on here what is
happening where does this happen
he was fine last night and then boom and
it's like what happens when you
hurt and and you go i just want to
shut down well you know it's good to
chill a little bit but but but also and
you lean on other people but then you
lean on others you
you come back out you say the sun's
coming up tomorrow
i think that's that's why we're we
didn't plan to share this but we're both
hurting yeah
different ways and it's like you know
what there's no competition with grief
man no there is and there's a lot of
people hurting right now
a lot of people hurting and are
listening today you dialed in and you're
going okay we got delony and coleman
but maybe you were supposed to listen
today because you've been through a
season of pain maybe you're in a storm
right now where it just feels like
financial storm or professional storm
relationship store maybe it's all three
can i just tell you
a we know what it feels like we've been
through all three
we're sitting in it right now we're
sitting in it now
yeah it's been a heavy season yeah and i
want to give people permission to both
stop and exhale yeah
take a knee and pray look at other
people and say
this just sucks i wish there was another
thing to say and
if you are in a season of sunshine right
now yeah
that's where you walk alongside
everybody else